تفاصيل جديده كشف عنها مصدر قيادي في
القسام عن عمليه التفجير شرق المغازي
والتي ادت الى مقتل اكثر من 20 ضابطا
وجنديا اسرائيليا وكانت ذات تسلسل غير
معتاد بحسب القيادي فان عددا من مقاتلي
قسام تمركزوا منذ اسابيع في منطقه العمليه
شرق المغازي رغم القصف الشديد والمتواصل
من قبل قوات
الاحتلال واصدرت لهؤلاء المقاتلين تعليمات
بعدم التعامل مع القوات المتوه في البدايه
في مخيم المغازي في انتظار هدف ثمين بحسب
المصدر واشار الى ان قوات الاحتلال كثفت
نيرانها على المنطقه ثم قامت بتمشيطها عبر
قوات البريه حتى ظن الاحتلال انها اصبحت
امنه فقام بادخال قوات الهندسه في هذه
الاثناء كان مقاتلوا القسام يرصدون القوه
الاسرائيليه تتقدم باتجاههم وتم تشخيصها
على انها قوه هندسيه من خلال هويه ومعدات
القوه التي
تستخدمها وتجاهل مقاتل القسام قوه راجله
اخرى كانت تقف فوق حقل الغام اعدته القسام
مسبقا انتظر مقاتل القسام القوه الهندسيه
حتى انهت عملها وثبتت الحشوات المتفجره
وقبيل خروجها من المبنى تم استهدافها
بقذيفه مضاده للافراد فعملت القذيفه كمحرض
للمتفجرات مزروعه واحدثت انفجارا هائلا
دمر المبنى وقضى على افراد
القوه بالتوازي مع ذلك استهدف المقاتلون
دبابه كانت تعمل على تامين القوه وقتل
واصيب من فيها لتاتي بعد ذلك قوات النجده
لمكان العمليه فمرت فوق حقل الغام مزروع
مسبقا فتم تفجيره ثم انسحب مقاتل القسام
بسلام بحسب المصدر واشار المصدر الى ان
القوات الاسرائيليه قصفت محيط العمليه
لعزلها واستقدمت اليات ثقيله بقيت تعمل
نحو ا عش ساعه لانتشال القتلى
الاسرائيليين من تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
الله